hey guys Ryan right over here hi Lauren
go over here Lauren look this is my
channel and you're scooting me over to
the left too much can you skews the
right I just asked you five seconds ago
if I was wondering hi I know but I have
to establish my authority on camera so
today is another unboxing video I didn't
know this was a thing until I was doing
my first one that I'm like no people do
unboxing videos I like Tyrone Magnus
recently I discovered has 1up box I
specifically avoided Tyrone's video so I
didn't know what was in here yeah for
those who you don't know 1up box it's
pretty much it's kind of like a loot
crate if you don't know what that is
here's our worst you pay like a monthly
membership twelve bucks a month you get
a 1up box which features all kinds of
Nintendo themed stuff and this month's
theme is villain I made sure to be a
part of it because I [ __ ] love
everything that's in here that comes
with an exclusive shirt only sold for
1up box I showed her the last one that's
right I showed her everything thinking
it would like impress the hell out of
her which it did open this box and see
what's in it let's see what's in the
villa month this is Kelly
Lauren you do the honors what oh my gosh
you just pull out each item at a time
don't look in there just do it by
feeling it with your hand don't look
just okay Harley Quinn know and love
Harley Quinn it's a pocket pop pocket
keychain of Harley Quinn it's so here's
a minute okay refocus this for you guys
now I got a Batman keyring I'm gonna put
the Harley Quinn keyring on
that's right now I look like a super bat
fan
yeah thanks 1up box a picture of my
nipples you are wrong it's the Joker
about March 2015 villain oh they're not
gonna be able to see this I know hold on
whoa look at that
oh we could do that that would have made
my life easier but now this is already
started while we're sitting on a whoopee
cushion today yeah okay so it's the
Joker theme one two you guys can see
that you guys didn't see that whoopee
cushion all right
Lauren can do the honors of blowing this
okay I'm not gonna make [ __ ] jokes if
you were actually blowing during a
[ __ ]
that would be the worst experiment I
don't understand why do they call it a
[ __ ]
I know because if you're blowing on it
feels weird all right
blow it Lauren this your boyfriend ever
say it to you like that no he's never
just like blow it Lauren go [ __ ]
yourself
there you go there you go yeah and I'll
sit on it you would to like pretend like
you place it there secretly okay we're
gonna do a little okay Lauren and I at
our best acting come in the door's
unlocked
hey Lauren
great seeing you again oh my god please
have a seat I don't know even though I
know you didn't really fart the fact
that it was supposed to imply a fart
makes me not want to touch it now no
it's gross stop put it somewhere else
all right next item okay oh it's a
legend of grete Legend of Zelda wallet
cool Oh cute that is pretty cool okay
okay okay look at that yeah BAM
wait no I
that's what other genitals No
that's true that's a cool cutout right
here okay yeah no give you the next
thing okay a Darth Vader a card I think
it's a sticker a dark Vader sticker look
at that people 1up box is joining
the set you just stuck two posters
together which is a really permanent
move yo yeah did you can't even see it
in the shot can see the shot at all Oh
with the Mario go wait like a little so
you know what he here you think oh
that's cool why not box is like really
pimping out your keychain
stop I'm open my house key on here for
those who want to breaking in my home my
house key cool
who is Zelda poster that's only gonna
strip my sister
give me that to my sister she's gonna
love it she's gonna love it she's gonna
love her that's great that's another
thing too is like if you don't really
want it you can give it away to someone
who would really want it but like this
[ __ ] I've seen this kind of [ __ ] at Hot
Topic that's like this is nine bucks
alone a hot dog oh yeah that's like
$7.99 it's time for the t-shirt all
right here we go I gotta tell them to
send me a large but here we go share a
joke team bast I'm team Billy I don't
like a Christmas shirt it does the
colors are very that's cool that's cool
it's really a small yeah look how tiny
this looks do that will not finish why
don't you just put it on
all right people 1up box is my arms look
kind of good in this though yeah 1up box
thank you for sending me a small because
I look better oh my god I can't breathe
remember Pirates of the Caribbean when
that corsage was like killing Keira
Knightley
that's a corsage I can't breathe I could
give it to Veronica hey guys yeah I put
a link in the description box if you
want to get a 1up box I'm gonna be doing
these every month because I like to
share with you the fun toys I get aget
because you guys have helped me grow
this channel so much so rather than
giving back I'm giving more to me that's
the way youtubers should do it if you're
new to the channel you should you check
out lowering Goss channel a lot of fun
[ __ ] on there you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter and you
have a good time one up thumbs up so I
feel like you would want to do four
thumbs up versus just one thumb up